King safety is the most important
strategic theme in chess at least the
one that you need to be the most careful
about because you can have a beautiful
pawn structure but if you get mated the
game is still over Nigel short once said
I don't know why people worry about pawn
structure so much because checkmate ends
the game okay guys how's everybody doing
good excellent so we're gonna be talking
about strategy and what I thought I'd
start with is a blindfold sign mold it I
gave earlier this afternoon it was 10
boards and there were actually a couple
of interesting games that I think are
gonna provide a good segue for us to
start talking about actual strategy that
can translate into tournament games but
first of all you know when you I don't
know if any of you have ever tried
playing blindfold or doing blindfolds
I'm illiterate experience and it's one
that I started investigating and trying
to perfect because I thought it captured
the essence of chess for someone who
knows absolutely nothing about chess you
know imagine somebody just walking by
the street doesn't know what a knight is
letting alone how it moves if he sees
someone that's blindfold play against
ten people at the same time he's gonna
get it like right away like that there's
something interesting about it there's
something that goes beyond simply
looking at a board and moving around
some pieces so I of course just started
playing with one opponent and and then
when I figured that wasn't a problem I
went up to two and three and so on and
the most I've done is ten which is what
I did today and there are a couple of
interesting
tips that I learned from a very good
book called blindfold chess and that is
to break up the ten boards for example
into little groups for example my first
four boards
I played efore as white boards five and
six I decided to play with the black
pieces and then board seven through ten
I played with white but I played d4 so
actually I'm not playing ten boards I'm
playing one sine wall where I played
efore on four boards so I have four
boards over here I'm playing black on
two boards over there and then I'm
playing white but I played d4 on the
other four so instead of juggling ten
random games I actually have three
ordered groups and I can always just dig
into each group and that really does
ease the task in any case I want it to
start off with this game this was one of
the games that I played with black here
you can actually see a name of my
opponent because I committed the
oversight of not asking all of my
opponents to write down their names
datura got started so probably the next
couple days I'm gonna be name hunting
and trying to to find out who I was
playing but anyway like I said I was
playing black in this game I'm gonna go
through the opening fairly quickly
because it's a fairly standard opening
and the ideas to talk about strategy
today although as we'll see later I
think that strategy and the opening are
very closely related and if you're smart
about it you can actually set up a very
comfortable game if you're familiar not
necessarily with memorizing opening
theory but with just some general
principles that can guide you from the
opening all the way throughout the game
probably till the end game anyway so
this is a dragon Sicilian and now my
opponent played this move Bishop c4
let's start off with the widest possible
division we can make in terms of
strategy and chess yeah this was your
game what's your name alright 9 to go I
got one alright so we're gonna be going
over this game excellent and don't leave
without giving me your full name because
I want to type it up on on the file so
like I was saying we're gonna start
talking about strategy let's make the
first really big division chest is
divided into strategy and tactics
strategy involves all our long-term
planning while tactics involves
immediate capitalizing on our opponents
mistakes or vice versa so what we're
gonna be talking about today is just
concepts that are gonna make our life
easier as the game goes along even
though we can't really appreciate it in
the short term so if chess is divided in
strategy and tactics I think that all
games that are lost can be traced back
to a tactical blunder or a strategic
blunder tactical blunders are easy I
mean we make them all the time you know
we're playing blitz we hang a knight
it's over we hang checkmate it's over we
hang the Queen it's over those are
tactical blunders and they're the
easiest to appreciate but sometimes we
don't make tactical blunders and we lose
anyway and we get this feeling of not
really knowing what went wrong because
there's no visible grotesque mistake yet
we lose anyway and it seems like we lost
fairly easily too and that is usually
because of strategic blunders and
strategic blunders are much harder to
perceive
and that is what I wanted to talk about
today now Bishop c4 is considered a
dubious move I wouldn't call it a
strategic blunder but as we'll see it
handicaps White's position from very
early on in the game the normal move
what usually plays here is f3 which
leads to the Yugoslav attack or Bishop
e2 which leads to much more positional
game but both f3 and Bishop e2 share the
common trait that they prevent the move
Knight g4 which Bishop c4 does not so
now after Bishop c4 Black has this very
unpleasant move Knight g4 which is
basically going to cost white his bishop
pair I was during the game I was
wondering well what would happen if
something like Bishop g5 and here I
started analyzing moves like Queen b6
which looked pretty annoying because
this knight on d4 is hanging we see the
pawn on b2 is also hanging and the pawn
on f2 is under serious pressure as well
so it doesn't seem like we can move the
bishop away the other alternative would
be to play a move like Queen d2 so that
against Knight takes III white can play
Queen takes III and at least keep his
pawn structure intact and I think this
is actually what white should have done
but in the game
Adie right you played castles here and I
think this is what I would call a
strategic blunder because it's a move
that you're not going to lose any
material that what's going to happen is
your position is going to reach its peak
very very early on in the game because
after Knight takes III F take c3
you've lost two major strategic
advantages you have an advantage in
development so that's absolutely true I
mean you've developed all your pieces
you canceled your King you opened up the
F file that's very nice but you've lost
two very important elements in your
position the bishop pair and you've
taken on a very bad pawn structure at
what we have here on III and II four are
the dreaded doubled isolated pawns
probably the weakest kind of pawn
structure you can find in chess so
anytime you can avoid this kind of pawn
structure you definitely should do it
because even though it might seem like
you'll get to create some threats and
maybe some initiative on the kingside
particular along the F file you're
basically forced to give checkmate or
suffer for the rest of the game and
looking at this position I really don't
think that White has a powerful enough
initiative to go for checkmate so when
you give up two strategic elements like
the bishop pair and the pawn structure
you need to have something very very
real for it because what's going to
happen now is that White's position is
gonna go slowly downhill even though you
haven't made any tactical mistakes so
let me just go on and show a couple of a
few more moves of how this game went and
then I'm going to turn to another game
played in the Simon so castles queen of
3e six and already we see that in two
moves Black has basically neutralized
the most dangerous aspects of White's
position which are the bishop on c4
which is putting pressure on f7 and
pretty much the F fall as well because
what once Black has canceled the rook on
f8 protects f7 which can later be over
protected by Queen c7 so I think that
already this
very bad position for white so after a
rookie one there's definitely some ideas
to put pressure on this backward pawn so
a six Queen g3 Queen c7 Bishop b3 97
Knight f3 and after 95 black makes it
just in time to stop the last threat on
his position which is the pawn on d6 and
the game went Knight takes Bishop takes
and I would like to stop here because I
hope that everybody can more or less
appreciate that Black has a big
advantage here we see the better pawn
structure see the bishop pair we see a
minor piece on a central outpost another
element of strategic importance here and
an outpost that cannot be readily
challenged by white because white has a
light square bishop that's not looking
too great because it's running into
black's pawn chain and this knight on c3
which in the Sicilian is is usually
White's nightmare it's gonna take this
Knight a long time to get to challenge
this Bishop on e5 so do we have any
questions so far about strategy versus
tactics strategic blunders versus
tactical blunders I hope that with this
game we get a clear idea of what a
strategic blunder looks like so the
blender wasn't Bishop c4 rather it was
allowing Knight takes c3 forcing F takes
III this one's going to be a little bit
more complicated so in this game I was
playing with white
and I'm gonna go again through the
opening fairly quickly
and now after h4 what would you guys
play with black here let me propose two
moves g4 and Bishop h6 which one would
you prefer y-yes sir
beautiful yes sir yeah same thing
anybody else have any other ideas about
this position well that's absolutely
true so during the game I was only
considering g4 which I was intending to
meet with Knight g1 and what about now
it's clear that if white gets to capture
the pawn on f4 he's gonna have a very
good position because blacks King side
is completely wrecked yep in the back
okay Bishop h6 defending f4 and if I go
92
Queen a5 oops that's not legal
any other suggestions okay but f3 is
really not gonna make things that much
better right because yeah I mean it
gives the pawn back so that's the good
news that you're not going to be down
upon the bad news is that your position
is gonna be terrible anyway because
let's say after Bishop takes e to again
let's take a tally of what are the
strategic Trump's for each side so what
does white have in its favor here yeah
the bishop pair is the most obvious what
else yes okay so he has an advantage in
development that's true in the back
right black cannot castle so King safety
is going to be another important
strategic factor here what can black say
that you know to his advantage yeah
he has less pawn islands right yeah so
okay you know if we're trying to be nice
and say something nice about black we
could say he has less plans and that
would be true but still I mean the
position it doesn't seem like less plan
islands makes up for you know White's
fish of pear his development the King
specifically the King safety King safety
is the most important strategic theme in
chess at least the one that you need to
be the most careful about because you
can have a beautiful pawn structure but
if you get mated the game is still over
Nigel short once said I don't know why
people worry about pawn structure so
much because checkmate ends the game and
there's certainly some value to that
because it's easy to overvalue your pawn
structure and maybe underestimate an
opponent's attack so pawn structure and
King safety should be constantly weighed
because it's not like one is more
important than the other you really need
to have a good balance between the two
was anybody raising their hand okay no
so after g4 91 I was thinking that there
could be some problems after Bishop h6
92
if black tried to do something like
Queenie 7 but then I'm not forced to
really capture on it for you
I think I can go d4 and overall it seems
like white has good chances of getting
this pawn on f4 back still I think black
should have tried going for something
like this in the game after h4 black
went Bishop h6 and I think this is also
a strategic blunder because after H
takes g5 Bishop takes Knight takes Queen
takes how would you guys evaluate this
position is white better is black better
why yeah why is why is white better
okay what about whites king safety is it
better than blacks here a couple moves
away from castling queenside and black
is threatening queen g3 and check me so
black is threatening Maiden - oh but
then he five is hang so it's one of
those cases where it's very easy to to
put too much weight on pawn structure
and Bishop pair when we pay absolutely
no attention to King safety and King's
safety is a major theme that we should
always at least be evaluating it and
asking ourselves who has better King
safety
are there any threats to my king these
seem like obvious questions but
sometimes it's easy to get too excited
that we have the bishop pair that we
have a better pawn structure that we
completely forget about our King so it
turns out the black has two threats here
Queen takes e5 and Queen g3 which one
should we stop yeah
ah excellent did everybody hear that so
we need to stop Queens III this is just
a very nasty threat because if we go
Queenie to thinking that we defend be
five and also against Queen G 3 we can
go Queen F 2 which would be very nice
we're gonna run into probably Bishop g4
here and this is not gonna be helping us
too much so there's no need to despair
because once we've taken a tally of the
pluses in our position
Bishop air pawn structure and we've
recognized the dangers of our King
safety we can actually use one of the
most powerful tools that strategy has to
offer us which is compensation
justifying a material imbalance with
strategic advantages so I'm sorry what
was your name iris so what iris
suggested is exactly that with Queen f3
we stopped the most important threat of
Queen g3 and of course now Bishop g4
doesn't do much for us because we can
just go Queen takes f4 we get the pawn
back we'd protect a 5 and we retain all
of our advantages so black is basically
forced to go Queen takes e5 and here is
the really difficult move Queen e2 these
are some of the hardest moves to find in
chess because it's just simply tough to
visualize your pieces moving backwards
right after you move them forward we
have this built into our chess DNA of
always trying to push forward so moves
where you're retreating especially right
after you've advanced or
counterintuitive but Queen e2 is a very
strong move because in the game my
opponent played f6 hoping for Queen
takes e5 of course we're not going to do
Bishop takes f4 queen takes bishop takes
this is a very unpleasant and game for
black black has an extra pawn but he has
a completely shattered King side two
isolated pawns on h7 and f6
also white is threatening to capture on
c7 so there's an immediate threat that
needs to be dealt with but white also
has the bishop pair and some open files
for his rook the rook on h1 is already
enjoying a very active file and the
other route can come to b1 and may be
combined with ideas like a4 a5 create
pressure as well so the positional this
is usually called like a positional pawn
sacrifice is a very important tool in
strategy and you not only have
positional pawn sacrifices you have
exchange sacrifices as well you have
players like wolf Anderson or Vaseline
to Paulo who use this tool constantly I
mean if you sort through the games of oh
Anderson even though he's considered one
of the positional masterminds of all
time in chess you would not think that
he would be sacrificing a lot of
exchanges right we usually associate the
exchange sacrifices you know crazy
tactics and finding a force variation
but it's actually an important strategic
tool and the fact that you find it in
the games of Wolff Anderson I think is
proof of that
so the game went c6
Bishop f3 castles King d2 and eventually
I ended up winning the game I combined
ideas of putting pressure on both sides
with rook h4 perhaps trying to play a
rook h1 but also well I'll just show you
how this worked out so you get an idea
how to combine play in both flanks which
is one of the main advantages that the
bishop pair can offer you once you have
the bishop pair in an open position it's
very easy to shift from one flank to the
other so rook h4 Bishop f5 rook e1 g5 a4
takes rook a1 and well at this point my
opponent made a tactical blunder so it's
nice to see a tactical blunder just to
compare it to the strategic blunders
we've been talking about yeah yeah so
Bishop d6 picks up in exchange now 96
Bishop takes Knight takes and we see the
other rook swings over to the Queen side
and all of a sudden what seemed to be a
king side pressure transforms into Queen
side pressure and aside from being up in
exchange white is also going to win the
a7 pawn and probably trade rooks into a
completely winning endgame okay so I'm
going to stop this game here because I
think the position is already pretty
hopeless for black any questions so far
talked about tactical blunder strategic
blunders now we're talking about tact as
strategic tools in this specific case
the pawn sacrifice and how we should
always be balancing pawn structure and
King safety it's no good to have a
perfectly safe king and a completely
shattered pawn structure or a perfectly
healthy pawn structure and a completely
exposed King
we're gonna run into trouble one way or
the other if we're lacking in one of
those two departments now what I would
like to do and something that I already
hinted at when we were getting started
is to illustrate this very close
relationship that strategy and opening
preparation have because one of the main
mistakes I see people make when they
study openings is that they'll simply
pick an opening that their favorite
player will play or an opening that's
just very popular at the moment and not
necessarily play an opening that comes
naturally to that player an opening that
is easy to understand where the idea is
straightforward and I think that should
be the number one priority when it comes
to choosing an opening that you're going
to invest time and energy and especially
if you play tournaments so I wanted to
start with the French defense advance
variation so c5 c3 Knight c6 Knight f3
Queen b6 a3 has anybody ever seen this
position before oh man okay how about
over there
no no what's your name yeah
so you've you played this with white or
with black you play this with black and
what do you usually play in this
position Bishop d7 that's a move why not
what are some other moves here that you
guys have played yeah I told you I get
to you know how do you you're saying
what would we say c-4 okay anybody else
in the back f6 definitely a key move in
the French defense anybody else
okay so we've mentioned three very
important moves I think also Knight h6
is considered to be the main line these
days but let's try to understand a
little bit what white is trying to do
and then according to that we can choose
our strategy so in the advanced French
usually white used to play Bishop e2 but
then he started running into some
trouble after C takes d4 C takes d4 and
Knight h6 because it turns out that this
d4 pawn is an important target for black
and it's not so easy to protect this
pawn because we can't really go Bishop
takes h6 because of Queen takes b2 and
we're gonna be losing some material and
we can't castle which is the most
natural move we could play because after
Knight f5 we simply lose the pawn on d4
there's nothing to be done here yeah
yeah absolutely yeah so I was just
mentioning like the two moves that white
can't play that or maybe the most
obvious but nice c3 is the main move and
what's your idea after Knight f5 how are
you going to solve this problem Knight a
four okay
and if I go Queen to a5 nice c3 back and
after Queen b6 yeah or you get a very
unpleasant King f1 okay
maybe what's that why did she play King
f1
wait King f1 where after after here King
f1 yeah
you've lost this with black once well I
mean it can happen I'm not sure what the
theory is on this but I would be a
little bit nervous like what happens if
I just go Queen d8 what's that
h4 or maybe g3 and if I Castle suspect
you're gonna go Kim G 2 and now maybe f6
I suppose this is playable but I also
get the impression that black is gonna
be doing pretty okay in any case this is
the main line if you ever want to play
Bishop e2 you have to know this idea of
Knight c3 oops
and Knight a 4 so it's not doing the
arrows but
one day a player with white came along
and he said well you know what I don't
like putting my King on f1 and then
allowing black to play f6 so I'm gonna
try to solve the problem of protecting
d4 in a different way so that if you go
Knight h6 I can go before and now after
takes takes Knight a5 I've taken care of
the main problem in White's position
which is protecting the b2 pawn since
this Queen on b6 has two purposes right
putting pressure on d4 and b2 so now I
can defend d4 very easily I can defend
with Bishop e3 or I can even defend with
Bishop b2 of course this is a very
theoretical variation but it's one
that's playable for both sides now
there comes a moment in everybody's life
where you have to choose whether to gain
space or keep the tension generally you
should try to keep the tension one of
the most common strategic mistakes and
one of the easiest strategic mistakes to
make is to forget about the center and
start gaining space and particularly in
the French defense that can be a problem
however I would say that's the rule
that's the strategic rule that's what
our general principle that should guide
us throughout our games but good players
know all the general principles very
good players know when they can find an
exception so in this case well pension
c4 you did c4 is a move that I really
like and it's a move that for some
reason is not being paid that much
attention to recently but it's a move
that gains space at the expense of
central tension so we can completely
forget about ever putting more pressure
on d4 that is over
but nevertheless this is a very
problematic move for white why is this a
problem yeah
right exactly so black has created an
outpost on b3 so we're not just
balancing two strategic themes which are
central tension and the gaining of space
there's a third element at play which is
an outpost so we seize an outpost as
well and I think that's what justifies
this decision that's what makes this an
exception to the rule
sure we've given up on the central
tension but we've gained control over an
outpost so whenever you have a general
principle that you're about to break you
should try to phrase it as a sentence I
have given up on the central tension but
I have gained and there you can place
your justification for breaking the rule
so in this case we gave up on the
central tension but we gained an outpost
and it's an outpost it's easily
accessible for black we have this idea
of Knight a5 it's coming very soon so
let me just show you how my game
continued just to give you an idea on
how once I seized the right idea in the
position for example I seize control of
the outpost now my entire strategy is
going to revolve around that outpost and
making the most of it so I'm not going
to get distracted and start attacking on
the kingside or anything like that here
I need to gain control of b3 so my
opponent played 92 so Knight a5 Bishop
b2 Bishop d7
castles 97 rook e1 h6 and rook b1 so how
would you guys play with black in this
position well know anybody in the back
yeah
okay so let's take a look at this so
Knight B 3 Knight takes Bishop a4 and
what happens if I drop back with the
other night
okay so see takes b3 but now what had
happened
we lost the outpost so an outpost is a
very delicate thing an outpost is like a
flower no I'm just kidding it's a very
delicate thing because it can't be
occupied too soon and it can't be
occupied by a pawn because if we occupy
it too soon we run the risk of
transforming the pawn structure in a
negative way there are two kinds of move
in chess that you need to be very
careful about and those are pawn moves
and piece traits and there's a third
move that kind of brings it all together
and those are piece trades that change
the pawn structure so any kind of move
that does any of those things you should
identify as the critical moment in the
game this game that is going to be the
turning point in this game so Knight b3
would be a strategic blunder because
you're changing the pawn structure in a
way that's going to impact your position
quite negatively because you've lost
your outpost which was your strategic
advantage in this position and also I
would venture to say that this pawn on
b3 is probably going to become weak
later on yeah in the back
okay that's a fair point
so knight c6 let's see can I do
something else here
hmm
that's an interesting night a five I
don't think I can do some crazy tactics
here
what's that
I was looking at Bishop takes c4 but
this doesn't really work out because b3
is hanging so we're just gonna lose a
piece I was also thinking maybe I could
go Knight takes e4 so so so yeah so that
against takes takes and I defend b3 but
no Knight a5 turns out to be
particularly unpleasant but what I could
do is simply let you get your piece back
and see what happens if all those
massive piece piece traits are gonna be
helpful for white or for black so let's
say I start with Bishop h5
so what's that okay so g6 and I don't
know if I have liked Bishop takes g6 and
Queen g4 maybe maybe not well maybe yes
I don't know
all right let's let's say I just retreat
and I swim you go Knight a5 and now I go
Queen e2 so you take take and Bishop
takes this seems like a fairly normal
position but I don't think that white is
necessarily facing any serious problems
of course we're playing with black so we
already have a comfortable game I think
the result of the opening has been a
resounding success for black but I think
we can actually hope for more in this
position and playing Knight b3 might be
jumping the gun on the outpost occupying
it a little bit too soon so
how can we strengthen our control over
the outpost before we actually occupy it
yeah
okay I like that idea definitely trying
to get this Bishop on a four is gonna be
a big part of black strategy but there's
a different way of doing this and what I
played here it was Queen c7 can anybody
see the idea behind Queen c7 yep
nope
yep there we go
yep so it's important not to lose track
of what's really important so we want it
make use of the b3 outpost we want to
try to get the bishop on a4 which would
increase our control over the outpost
and the move b5 really wouldn't help us
to do this it would actually block our
pieces from ever getting to the outpost
so the idea of Queen c7 is actually to
maneuver the knight to b6 so let's see
what happened in the game 9f 198 Bishop
f4 Knight b6 also it's worth noticing
that I'm in no rush to castle in this
position we have a closed center which
means that the King usually in those
situations
feels pretty safe in the center we
shouldn't forget the castling is a
defensive move it's a passive move and
many times I've seen this many times
people simply castle out of habit and
even castle into an attack for example
castling kingside would be suicide for
black white is gonna play Queen d2 93
Bishop takes h6 so if anything black is
gonna Castle queenside but the general
principle that I like to use is that if
you have a useful maneuver or a piece
that you can improve that should take
precedence over castling again unless
King safety becomes a major issue so
when King safety is an issue that has
priority above everything else but in
this case we see that this King looks
pretty safe honey egg for the moment I
mean there there are no white pieces
anywhere near this King so that's why I
had enough time to play Knight c8 96 so
now after Queen d2 castles Queen e3
Bishop e7 h for rook g8 and Bishop a4 is
coming it's just a matter of time but
it's not like white can do much to stop
black's plan on the Queen side so I'm
simply preparing some King side play so
Bishop a4 and I think at this point we
can conclude that blacks opening
strategy has been a major success but
what was black's opening strategy I mean
we just talked about an opening and it
doesn't feel like we really memorized
many moves and and I can assure you
there are many games that have been
played up and well maybe a couple until
a couple of moves earlier but what did
we do that made it so easy yeah my
opponent by the way is a 2300 player so
he knows what he's doing
yeah yeah we identified an advantage in
our position early on and we simply
drove at home we made it so that all of
our moves maximized that advantage so
that we were able to capitalize on this
outpost that we have on b3 and I think
that's a very powerful strategy to use
in the opening choose openings where you
can identify a target early on in the
game that will allow all of your moves
to flow naturally around that target so
that's why I like the c4 move so much
against the advanced French because it's
move six and we're like okay b3 is an
outpost all of our pieces are going to
go towards b3 we even have this I had
actually seen this maneuver Knight c8
Knight b6 and some I think it was a
Korchnoi game so you can supplement
these ideas with your actual study with
going over Grand Master games you can
see what are some little tricks that
they use
to maximize that strategic advantage
that they're getting very early on so
the game went Bishop d1 Bishop takes
rook takes but having traded lights for
bishops any player here that plays the
French on a regular basis can attest to
the fact that it's a pretty good feeling
so Knight a four Queen f4 rook F 893
Queen b6 and again we see that all of
the pieces always pushing towards the
outpost ie I spent a few moves preparing
a possible King side attack but unless I
saw something very clear I really didn't
lose my focus on what really mattered in
this position which was the Queen side
so once the Queen site is secure then
very slowly very steadily I can start
preparing moves like g5 or f6 and start
opening up the King side and create an
additional team usually I'm I'm sure you
guys have heard this the verrat ski
concept opening up a second front
so one target is not going to be enough
to win the game so we're not gonna win
the game just because all of our pieces
are on b3 in fact if we overdo it we
realize that we can't put more than one
piece on one square and we've misplaced
many of our pieces but once we've
secured b3 we can start creating some
cracks in our opponent's position in
another part of the board and that's
what palm breaks are for so in the
French the f6 pawn break is a very
useful tool for that and when we were
talking about move six and we ended up
investigating the c4 move somebody had
mentioned f6 which is also a very
interesting move and a move that even
though we don't play it right away
we don't discard it forever it's still
going to be part of our strategy the
timing is just going to be a little bit
different so in this position my
opponent went a little bit crazy and he
tried to open up the queenside and
follow up with this sacrifice in order
to create some King safety problems for
me now I made well actually
the move I made here it was knight c6
this was fine and after rook takes b3 I
made a terrible blunder and lost the
game
what should black play here
everybody sees why I can't take the rook
on b3 right okay so that that's gonna be
the starting point of the analysis here
if Queen takes b3 Queen c7 checkmate
yeah takes on so it takes on e6
interesting and
it takes on e6 what happens if white
goes something like queen g4
yeah then you can probably take the rook
right and queen takes c6 King d8 it
looks a little bit scary but I think you
can probably get away with it let's see
is there any other option so f takes c6
rook well what I could do is rook takes
b6 right and after rook takes a for work
takes c6 check B takes c6 Bishop takes
f4 wait it's gonna be up a pawn but you
can probably count well I don't know if
you can capture on c3 or a three right
away maybe on c3 right because if rook
c1 you have 90 - yeah what was that
green d8 here that's what I played and
it didn't work out so well
FTC six might work
yeah in the back
you're saying Queen a5 well bit maybe I
don't have to play rook b1 against Queen
85 maybe I can go eat takes f7 and open
up more lines against the black King
yeah oh yeah nice yeah definitely so the
important thing here is first to
identify what is the strength of White's
position white has a very powerful
coordination with his Bishop on g3 Queen
on f4 and rook on b3 there they are all
converging on the Queen side effectively
overloading the black queen this black
queen can't defend everything so we need
to find a move that disrupts this
coordination yeah
Knight takes c3 interesting so if Rick
takes b6 you want to go 90 to check but
what if I go rook takes c3 F takes six
and can I try to go something like Queen
III
oh wait a minute no 9c3 Brooks III fe6 I
can play
can i play Queen b8 well but you O king
b7 right it actually it's actually not
help I lose the Queen but yeah I mean
giving the piece back and still enduring
a devastating attack I don't find it too
appealing but there's a way we can
disrupt this coordination of whites and
that is what the move g5 so now if takes
takes Knight takes we can simply take on
g5 and now it's actually the white queen
that is overloaded because it can't
really keep attacking c7 it's being
threatened by the bishop and there's no
way to defend the rook as well so after
Queen takes simply Queen b3 and it's
game over I'm actually a little bit
curious about F takes c6 here
I was thinking we could do this but
maybe this isn't so clear right a knight
takes c3 this actually looks good for
black well we can go rook e1 and rook
takes six
yeah this looks like a pretty good
position for black I mean maybe we can
go rook III and 95 well hold on you're
getting ahead of yourself
yeah so this Bishop is hanging as well
before okay but now 95 and whoops
it looks like you might have some
problems on the kingside right and also
defending c6 isn't going to be so easy
because you can't stay on d6 or c7
because of the discoveries
in this position well I think again
probably 95 is gonna be unpleasant right
yeah so f takes e6 looked like an
interesting move because it also aimed
to disrupt White's coordination in his
attack it looks like white has this
tactic so so g5 is the key because now
white doesn't have the possibility of
taking on b6 because you're not waiting
a rook on f4 you're just winning a pawn
so if you take on c6 and take on f4
you're gonna find a very unpleasant
surprise when you start counting the
pieces here and realize that you're down
at rook so I'm just going to show you
how I ended up losing this game I played
Queen d8 and after a takes f7 then I
figured it out but it was too late
because now Queen f5 27 takes takes rook
takes p7 and even though the Queen's are
off the board black still has some very
serious King safety problems here this
would be another case but this this time
I'm on the receiving end of a strategic
compensation for a material deficit in
this case white is down a piece but his
compensation lies on my very poor King
safety here and also he has a couple
pause which helps so after King e6 rook
e1 king of 695 this position is
basically lost for black okay and we're
supposed to run till 8:30 right is that
yeah okay so that's basically all I have
to show you today I don't know if
anybody has any questions before we wrap
it up but I'm hoping that with these
games I can get you to think about some
very common very old ideas in a slightly
different way in a slightly more
integrated way in a way that you can
actually take ideas and balance them
during a game
and figure things out really before it's
too late because that's the big danger
with strategy timing is everything and
it's easy to realize things once they're
too late
if you're lucky sometimes like I said
you lose the game and you don't even
know why you lost so the study of
strategy is meant to address exactly
that alright guys thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
you